hello everyone my name is meanwhile i
come from micro sorry sir asia the demo
I'm going to do right now is a junk
walker between Microsoft Research
Cambridge and Mike Rosario to Asia
because inside the cloud is to explore
the new interactions for cloud computing
socal computing calls for the new UI
metaphors and new hardware technologies
to enable the more natural user
interfaces so club moss is one such of
this technology with grandma's I can
access my data my information is a cloud
anywhere so here is a real demo here you
can see all those information are
rendered he like the universal concept
all those information on the top
although some task I'm going to work on
right now today all those people's I'm
going to connect I'm going to
communicate today so I came to me to say
what happened past and what going to
happen in the coming days I also can
switch to the side view to see all those
summaries for my job and my
communications and my task so I came
back to the front view and can push into
my slack one task to see our ok there
how many documents you need how many
task I need to work out so now shows all
those documents and the people's for
these tasks back to the home page and
switch you to my home scenarios sinkoff
you help this club moss and when you
back to home you want to see some of the
entertainment and some of those game
some of those pictures you take so now I
drag this picture a wall to the center
and it shows all those pictures and emo
bride views I can use chrome oz 22
browsing age I also can switch to
another pictures to look into it to do
me into the moat detailed in from to see
more detailed information to see a big
picture and I can share this with my
friends so I just graduated share with
my friends and also i can drag these
pictures to share to another device so i
drag it share to this data frame so
summarize the damn i just showed today
is the new interactions for cloud
computing
you